here we go from normal brownie to ruin
Rudy who knows hi I'm Matthew I'm a
tasty producer and today my friends
asked me to make some brownies but I
think there's some kind of you know
problem that they're gonna throw at me
apparently there is a secret ingredient
that I have to incorporate into them Oh
what am I gonna do
okay so I can go for it all right here
we go okay come on fine
don't be horrible pickled vegetables and
brownies can I make my own pickles in
order for something to be qualified as a
pickle it has to be brined in acid sugar
and salt so essentially I'm gonna make a
sweet pickle they are still qualifying
as pickled vegetables but they're gonna
be more delicious when it comes to a
dessert while the Bryan liquid is coming
to a boil I'm going to grate all four of
my colorful vegetables and I want to
have some other shapes to play with so
I'm going to slice some more of each of
the vegetables on a mandolin so now my
pickling liquid is out of oil so I'm
about ready to pour it over the
vegetables but I want to kind of flavor
leave even more so I think I'm gonna
make the beet and the carrot I would
breathe in some vinegar I'm gonna make
the beet and the carrots a little bit
orange flavored man I don't put some
lemon juice on the zucchini and golden
beet and here we go and I really just
need enough to cover each of the pickled
vegetables and there we go okay so I'm
gonna let all these vegetables sit in
there pick a liquid and I'm gonna move
on to the brownie batter I'm just using
our classic tasty 101 perfect brownie
recipe
so now the batter is looking good so far
and here's where things might go off the
rails I'm gonna start adding in the
pickled zucchini and carrot in order to
prevent it from completely ruining
leaves brownies
I want to dry them out as much as
possible so that way they don't affect
the consistency of the brownie batter it
really doesn't matter how long they're
sitting in the liquid as long as you can
taste it oh okay
this would not taste weird in a brownies
and the rules say I have to use all of
this Brian liquid still so I'm going to
save the pickle liquid for the caramel
and now I'm going to make sure I can dry
these out as much as possible but just
to ensure they don't just sink to the
bottom of the brownies I'm actually
going to toss a tiny bit of flour with
the carrots and zucchini that'll just an
ensure that they kind of stay all
throughout the brownie batter here we go
from normal brownie to ruin really who
knows here we go I've got one
homogeneous brownie batter fenomena set
this aside while I make the cheesecake
batters with the pickled gold beet and
pickled red beet I'm kind of making it
up as I go along for this part in goes
the golden beet and here's one egg
no I want to be smooth but maybe it's
like I just have to embrace that there's
gonna be a little bit of texture yeah to
do it man this little Oh some egg white
just a little bit of liquid
if the chunks look at unattractive all
just it's kind of strain it out later on
I want to move on and now I'm going to
make like a simple cheesecake batter so
in here I have one block of cream cheese
1 cup of sugar and I'm gonna put in two
eggs and it's gonna mix it until it's
smooth so I'm going to take some of the
white cheesecake batter out just in case
I want a little bit of a white floral in
there and then I'm going to divide the
other two halves into separate
containers so let's start with the
yellow I'm gonna work on the red beet
I'm comfortable those batter is going in
chunky with vegetables but it's all the
different side
with these little splotches of color I
want to put enough that it can mix in
but I don't want to be too much you know
what let's go crazy I'm gonna put a
little bit of normal cheese tick powder
in there too I think a little bit of
white will help the other colors pop
more alright so it looks kind of gross
now but I think after I spiral it it'll
look much better oh this does look
really cool okay see way better now it's
gonna go in the oven for about 20
minutes so here is all the leftover
brine liquid from all the vegetables I'm
gonna put into the pan you might add
even more sugar to make the caramel and
a mix of the sugar in with the pickle
liquid and basically I'm just gonna
bring this to a boil and cook it down
until it's almost syrupy almost like a
caramel oh I'm happy this looks really
cool so the brownies have been in the
oven for 20 minutes and now I'm gonna do
this really cool trick that really keeps
them fudgy what this does is sort of
crack the top a little bit and allows
the all of it to settle so it can be
really buggy and now I'm gonna sprinkle
on some flaky sea salt and now back into
the oven it goes so now my pickle liquid
has reduced and I'm gonna add in my
butter and heavy cream once this comes
to a boil we're good to go
right now my caramel is cooling my
brownies are about to be finished baking
and I have my co-workers downstairs
we're gonna have a blind taste test of
the brownies I hope it goes well right
now though I'm gonna plate it as
beautiful as I can to impress them are
those vegetables on the side that's
confusing
[Music]
that's an amazing brownie I might
actually eat this whole thing
that's a brownie right in the brownie
batter
there is pickin zucchini and pickled
carrots
Muniz cake top has pickled beets
[Music]
excellent a plus I hate zucchini I had
no idea so you win so it's a healthy
brownie well I'm glad they liked at all
I mean they're not healthy but I'm glad
I fooled them I'm proud of myself that I
could do it wasn't sure if I could but I
think it'll be the last time I make
rainbow pickled vegetable brownies
[Music]
you